jim garoppolo had his best year by far
last season with the san francisco 49ers
in part because he played the entire
season all the way through until the
super bowl yesterday coach kyle shanahan
spoke with chris sims on the unbuttoned
podcast about among other things his
quarterback here's some of the
conversation
you've told me a lot of positive things
about jimmy garoppolo he's unflappable
you know he has the right demeanor to
win but it also seems like the team
really loves jimmy g like tell us just
why what it is about him that seems to
make the guys kind of gravitate towards
him
um i mean i think it starts with your
talent first of all i mean the way he
throws the ball and stuff at practice
some of the plays he's made in games um
i mean guys believe in him um look at
our record here with him on the field
and our record without him um so it
starts with that but the way he carries
himself to the guys he's always one of
the guys um he's always himself
um he's when he comes in the building
he's
he's not the ceo of the building he's
like one of the guys you know they don't
they're comfortable around him he
doesn't act different he's he's their
age most of our guys i mean he's right
in the middle of the pack of everyone
and guys believe in them i mean when
you're like 4 and 22 without them and
then you have this record with them
that's and i know the circumstances were
different um you know especially their
defense and stuff but
guys know that and when he's gone in
he's made plays and it's just like the
practice field and when you have guys
like that i mean
guys are excited to play for him and
then when you're a good dude and never
he'll never throw anyone under the bus
no matter what right you see how good he
is to our teammates at the press
conference and everything and they know
he's got their back and so they got his
well let's see
what what's the teaching moment for
jimmy g last year you know just the last
thing on him i don't mean to beat this
to death but of course he's the
quarterback the super bowl team and
everybody talks about him but like what
do you take away from the year that
you'll try to preach to him is you know
the the banner theme for 2020 football
season
mine to jimmy is just that you're just
getting started no last year was your
first year playing quarterback for a
whole season like you've never had a
longer than a three-game stretch and
last year you got 16. and look how good
you did look how far we got and oh my
god we almost got all the way but that's
not the finished product and that's how
i feel about everything i feel about
myself i feel about our team like guys
that's we didn't just almost get there
we're still going and you have to get
better and what i like about our team is
when i'm talking about jimmy
how can he not get better he's played
one season
and that's just the starting point you
look at some of our receivers some of
our d linemen like we got guys who
almost played good enough and we almost
coached good enough last year first to
win a super bowl and that that's hard
it's a hard pill to swallow that it
wasn't enough what's really cool is when
i look at our team
and i'm not making stuff up
no one's at their peak individually our
guys should get better like our guys
they our guys can get better our
receivers can our d-line can our
quarterback can or bro we got we got
guys who can get better and that's
what's exciting and with jimmy i know
everyone thinks he's been the league so
long because he's gotten a second
contract and everything um but
quarterbacks with his ability um they
get better the more they play and the
more situations they're in and that's
the key for jimmy it's just to know that
and keep doing it
kyle shanahan with chris sims on jimmy
garoppolo and look
the narratives that emerged about jimmy
garoppolo last year resulted from a
couple of things first of all he had
some unfortunate throws in the
divisional round playoffs against the
vikings he threw three passes that
should have been intercepted by eric
kendricks one was the other two weren't
after the last one
the 49ers shifted to all run they stayed
in all run
through the divisional round through the
conference championship round creating a
question as to whether or not jimmy g
was going to be bob griese in super bowl
54 throwing the ball maybe eight or nine
times at most and then he came out and
threw it more and there was a time
before the chiefs turned it around
people were saying hey jimmy g is going
to be the mvp of the game shireen and
then it all came down to having the
opportunity to hit emmanuel sanders with
the game on the line he missed him and
that's kind of where we are like i i
they got a great team around jimmy g
i've yet to see anything that makes me
say
this is a top
top tier nfl quarterback and when you
have the opportunity to make that
championship throw and you miss it
that's your chance to bust through and
it's pass fail and it doesn't come very
often it came for jared goff last year
and it didn't happen it came for jimmy
garoppolo this year and it didn't happen
and until he makes a throw like that in
the super bowl that that ghost is going
to linger for
yeah i think i was just going to start
out i think i like jimmy g more than you
do mike and i do see him going to get
into that top tier of quarterbacks
you're right he still has that and he
has to get past that i understand that
was that last point that that kyle
shanahan made and and i was going to
make that same point is this is a young
older guy and that he's played six
seasons but he hasn't played six seasons
he hasn't played very many games
last year was his first 16 game season
as kyle shanahan pointed out the more
you play the better you get so this is a
young guy who knows the offense who
knows what he needs to do he knows how
to read defenses now i think we're going
to see jimmy g have one of the top two
or three
quarterbacks in the league this year i
really do i think he's going to have a
great season i think the 49ers are going
to have a great season on paper they
look terrific
if he can stay healthy i think this is a
team that you're going to look to be in
the nfc championship game if not advance
the super bowl again and give him
another opportunity to make those throws
that he didn't make in the fourth
quarter of the super bowl this year
and regardless of anything that kyle
shanahan said yesterday about jimmy
garoppolo jimmy g is on notice he knows
he's on notice he's addressed it himself
the idea that they evaluated tom brady
and kyle shanahan talks about that with
chris sims talks about why shanahan took
it head-on and told jimmy g about it but
they looked into the possibility of
bringing tom brady home to the team that
he grew up rooting for and there was
some thought that that was brady's first
choice and at the end of the day jimmy g
ended up being the 49ers first choice
but the message is not that anyone needs
to hear this if you're not getting it
done in the nfl they're going to find
somebody else and it applies at every
position and they are in the years of
the jimmy garoppolo contract where it's
very easy to move on if that's what they
choose to do minimal cap hit minimal
financial obligation they could move on
after 2020 they could have moved on
after 2019 with a very minimal cap hit
like 4.2 million dollars so uh hey
maybe that is the thing shireen that
nudges him to the next level that that
kind of backhanded
threat to his status if you want to be
the year to your quarterback of this
team and you want to hold this job the
way brady held it for as long as he did
in new england you got to step up and
you got to get it done and and we'll see
if that's the impetus for him to do it
he did so many great things in the
regular season he had over 100
passer rating during the regular season
he had four fourth quarter comebacks
which was the most in the nfl he did a
lot of great things uh in the regular
season in the postseason not so much
especially the fourth quarter of the
super bowl which is what we remember
right now he's got to get past that move
on get another chance to come back and
and redeem himself from that and yeah a
lot of quarterbacks you look at matt
ryan didn't get a chance to do that the
fourth quarter of the super bowl still
lingers and they haven't gotten back and
maybe they never get back
to the super bowl but you hope for jimmy
g's sake he does get a chance to get
back and make a play in the fourth
quarter and redeem himself
yeah and that's another thing that comes
up in the podcast uh you know i i was
critical of kyle shanahan
basically pressing the fast forward
button for 2020 to the point where
they're holding a 10-point lead with
seven minutes left in the fourth quarter
of the super bowl and i and and i said
this out of respect for him because i
think he of all the young coaches has
the potential to be the next bill
belichick and i could never see bill
belichick articulating that thought in
any setting because you have to
understand how hard it is to get back to
that spot how hard it was for them to
just get the one seed and win their
division it came down to the last drive
of the last game of the regular season
and it very easily could have gone
either way you know it's kind of like
the the corollary to the chiefs belief
that they can win all these
championships you got to thread the
needle over and over and over again and
in hindsight when you get to the end of
the road you look back and you realize
all the potholes that you missed and all
the all the other calamities that could
have happened to you that would have
knocked you off the road for good and
you somehow managed to miss it you know
just like the chiefs are going to have
the target on their backs all year long
the 49ers are going to have the target
on theirs and it's
the easy part is finishing the job with
seven minutes left in a 10-point lead
the hard part by far
is getting to the point where you have a
10-point lead with seven minutes to go
in the super bowl
yeah and it's a great point mike nobody
had the 49ers with the target on the
bull's eye on them hey we're aiming for
the 49ers last year i mean this was a
team that was coming off a losing season
and now they have that target how are
they going to play with the bulls eye on
them how are they going to play with
everybody wanting to knock them off hey
we beat the nfc champs we can you know
judge ourselves against that great 49ers
team and and
something else to pose they play in a
great division all those teams in their
division are going to give them a run
for their money so it's not even going
to be easy to win their division this
year much less get back to the super
bowl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports